welcome back to the Oskar red carpet
here at the Dolby theater this is so
exciting and we all can't wait to see
what Lady Gaga will wear on Sunday now
we do know she'll be rocking some new
ink the notes ga-ga
on her arm Gaga and Bradley Cooper star
is born'
journey will soon come to an end so we
want to look back on how it all began
here's when Bradley met Gaga he came
over to my home and he said I would like
to sing with you if that's okay
[Music]
I just stopped instantly in my tracks
and I looked at him and I said Bradley
you have an incredible voice you sing
from your gut and then he said should we
film it so he filmed it on his iPhone
[Music]
here is Bradley's 2016 footage that
shows their lightning in a bottle
chemistry from day one it was one of
those magical things and for it to be
Lady Gaga and have that connection and
then have that commitment from her
these candid behind-the-scenes moments
are part of a star's borns bonus DVD
materials there's really from that first
meeting it just was like a bomb that
went off that atomic energy also carried
over to Gaga's dropped the mic table
read Bradley was so confident in his
leading lady
he shot their screen test before even
writing the oscar-nominated script his
characters weren't really even born yet
I mean Jackson main didn't even exist
when I shot that test and I knew that
the camera was gonna love her face or
her eyes her whole energy and I thought
if I can capture that if I can write a
character if Eric Roth and I and will
Fedders can write a character that
facilitates and utilizes all of her
strengths that it could be it could be a
home run actually more like a grand slam
a star is born made over 423 million
dollars at the worldwide box office
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]